let's go next to Oh what could this be
we're going to a caller from country
code 44 country code 44 where are you
calling from what's your name and what's
on your mind today Tama Carden and I'm
calling from Northamptonshire United
Kingdom all right very good to hear from
you what's on your mind oh yeah yes I'm
a big fan
I do enjoy your podcast on YouTube and I
have been encouraging my colleagues and
friends also to watch because there are
big friends of TYT and democracy now and
I thought actually they may benefit from
watching you as well good so the reason
I'm calling and I'm hoping it's more
around constructive criticism rather
than destructive very good is okay
my background is adult mental health
social worker here in the United Kingdom
which I guess would be the equivalent of
a LCSW in the States
got it and I'm originally from the
states so I've had experience in both
and the reason I'm calling is because
obviously I've been watching quite
regularly your show and when you address
issues around mental health particularly
with our presidents and I know that you
have expressed your opinions in regards
to possible dementia yeah among other
issues and I think if I wanted to be
constructed I mean I don't know your
background I don't know if you have a
clinical background I don't or what your
qualifications are in regards to any
kind of clinical input around mental
health or around behavioral studies or
around mental health and I just I would
say what's the racism so I can handle it
I can see you're dancing around because
you want to be polite but I can take it
what am I saying that's wrong it's not I
think it's what I'm trying to say is I
wouldn't be diagnosing
someone if I don't have that background
right okay good I think I probably I
thought you were gonna go in a different
direction which is I shouldn't say Trump
is insane because that actually it has a
very particular stigma and connotation
and I try I really am trying to catch
myself on that because it's this
reflexive term I sometimes use and I
thought that was going to be your
criticism and it's not so let's let's
not go into that here I do I am aware of
the long-standing policy at least in the
American psychiatry Association and my
dad's a psychiatrist his wife is a
psychologist my girlfriend is a
therapist as well and I have a long
family lineage of mental health workers
and I understand the concept of not
diagnosing if you've not personally
examined someone I am sort of reporting
on I've never on a whim come up with the
idea that Donald Trump may be exhibiting
the early signs of dementia I am merely
reporting on what mental health
professionals are saying and I do
believe that that's an important
distinction if I was just making this up
out of thin air that I think would be
inappropriate reporting on the fact that
mental health professionals are
discussing this I do think is okay no I
I agree with you I think when I watch
your podcast though it hasn't always
been clear that this is what has been
reported or is it is what is being
inspired it came off as more of this is
my opinion which is fine and it should
be labeled as an opinion yeah but I
think it's also and the reason why
people probably hesitated which I'm glad
they haven't no I'm glad that they are
speaking up actually they have been
speaking up since 2015 but it's it's
more of the people I work with are not
usually with people with significant
mental health difficulties are not
individuals who usually are in positions
of power in an essence they tend to be
the most vulnerable the most exploited
and the most abused no question about
and taboos attached to them and they
just think it's what happens is is my
concern is and things are made like this
they can be taken flippantly and
- what you want to do is just open
dialogue rather than people feeling
attacked - God listen I think I get the
point
I am I in no way you know the reports
that I do are based on what mental
health professionals are saying if I
don't always make that clear I should
make a better effort - so point taken
and certainly no I'm pleased to hear
because like I said the other ones I
just hadn't heard and I think it's
fabulous and thank you very much for
taking my phone call
very good always great to hear from our
friends across the pond in the UK